so this first this notebook is about
making sure that all the stuff in easier
on can be run it seems like I don't know
if all all of them it seems like some
Windows machines are not able to unpick
all some of the objects so show of hands
who has gone through this page who's
gone through stage successfully okay um
so I will give a few more minutes for
people to go through this page I'll talk
about what's gonna set up and when why
this stuff is here
and before I get started with the main
material so as far as for it seems like
with some of the Windows machines that
have some pickled objects that don't
seem to be readable back on Windows
sorry I tried to I was going to move
away from pickling but there are some
objects that I couldn't save in a normal
serialize format so save the pickling
risky move did not pay off so good luck
if you're on Windows I'll try when I
update this in the future to maybe test
it out on a on a Windows machine and see
if I can get a Windows compatible
version
oh okay so that may be in an additional
one because using Python - when I pickle
them so I'm not surprised that okay so
uh so someone said that has you he
thinks was it was may be possible in
Python 3 so he changed to read binary I
know that alone did it work for some of
you but he also had it use with the
Latin one encoding so how to drive it so
down let's see here so they open so what
are you add here to make it work so you
did
[Music]
so I work on mine there's almost it
won't work on my macbook start running
here but if you're a Windows user you
want to add that to the list statements
some of you who are had the problems let
me know if it fix it for it all worked
ok ok awesome thank you for finding a
solution so let me run through this so
mainly I'm going to be using pandas and
a little of visualization format part
live and work and works out in the end
we'll do some stuff with SK learn but
we're not going to go into in depth so
I'm not expecting anyone to really
knowing who I see I learn I am sort of
expecting most people here have some
familiarity with pandas how many people
here do ok
yay so how many people here know would
have worked by this ok yeah so yeah it's
basically a image with some words where
their sizes are associated with some
weight so we're going to be using that
to explore our data set now I have some
exercises in here
I also have an answers module so if
you've downloaded it if you get to an
exercise it will like throw an error
until you've implemented it if you don't
want to do the exercise I have a
commented out import of the answer below
it so you can always just skip the
exercises if you want but that's not but
yeah not as well so if you've just
installed an LC k n LC k depends on some
data sets so you can go and download
them I think in there was an email sent
out asking you know users to install
some of these data sets the simple the
easiest smallest data set is the the
book collection
so if you have data set where I'll be
talking about this data set this is just
I put this notebook to try and find all
the errors oh this is why I modified
so this is see if I make sure I can find
as many errors as early as possible so
we'll give a three more minutes see to
have people try to get as much stuff
installed as possible how many people
have run this notebook successfully now
okay so I think I should definitely make
a branch of this project that's windows
compatible
that's all probably all working doing
that after this
[Music]
cannot importantly check there
okay ah
so which raises yeah ah oh um oh my god
oh so maybe that's a version of
excellence of try updating that
because I know that yes because there I
know beforehand I was using um which one
and this one I was importing from an
older module that scikit-learn had and I
would get a warning so I updated
scikit-learn
okay so I'm going to get started if you
have any problems and you are able to
write it I did include static HTML
versions of the run notebooks here so so
you can still follow along even if it
doesn't run so let's start talking about
what we're going to be doing today so
when you have a structured data set what
do you do to initially explore it you
you give you value counts on the columns
it can contain categorical data it's
numerical data you might do like a mean
you can plot histograms and do I have
you we know how to explore structured
data but how do we explore uncertainty
or how to explore text so the idea is we
want to find out what's being said in
the next so that of course is a very
nebulous statement and that's sort of
what this talk is looking to clear up so
what would will be some initial ways you
would think to explore text
yeah hmm cool
so I'm going to work on this dataset on
job description so these are job
descriptions from indeed and they were
used in a hassle ranked earlier this
year somebody here at people here have
written a job description okay cool
how many people have searched job
descriptions and use that to make a job
decision on which shell to get okay
imagine yes so so see what we're doing
so we're going to we're going through
the instruction now we're going to go
over tokenization we're going over
tf-idf so or I'll actually explain what
that is in case any of you don't know
what it is how many people here know
what tf-idf is okay cool how many and
how many people here have like some have
a Glee heard of it before
okay so we'll talk about visualizing
using TF idea and then we'll talk about
some other an NLP processes so stemming
aromatization to normalize the words
stop word removal so this is our way of
game very less use for words and grams
which was with us looking at sections of
the text and then in the end we'll do
some simple modeling just to explore how
these features can affect our models so
one thing uh one analogy I like to use
with NLP as it's like session so you
never want to go too deep or not deep
enough depending on your problem so you
want to figure out for your problem what
do you need to get out of the text and
then you figure out how do I get it to
that exact depth so in the case of what
we're doing here exploratory analysis we
don't need to go really super deep we
don't need to do you know like syntax
parsing or something like that because
we're just looking for a
a first pass understanding of what's in
our data on the other hand if in your
doing some much more complicated tasks
with a problem that has to do with you
know complicated statements made in the
text this cursory analysis wouldn't be
sufficient enough so Penelope it's
always first understand what you need to
solve your problem and then make sure
that you don't overshoot or undershoot
what you need
Oh question so see so here's our data
set so the columns we have are an ID
which is just a generated ID for each
job description
the description text as well as some
attributes of the of the job of the job
so how many years experience is required
how much education is part is the job
hourly is it the job part-time is the
job a supervisory position so here we
see that some of them there's no
experience required analogic a she
needed the other one so these are
categorical variables these are boolean
variables or calls I should say so we
have 4,300 jobs so let's see so one
thing to do I'm going to give Sarah a
civil with movies for text without
having to do any NLP let's look at the
character distributions or character
lengths I should say so here we have an
idea of how many characters are in our
job descriptions does anyone here think
this is a satisfactory exploration of
the data now that it yep okay well
clearly the problem is we have a
punctuation in there so let's only look
alphanumeric okay that didn't give us
any more information so clearly that's
not going to work we need to get at the
meaning of what's in our data
so meaning in language in in text
specifically are out also spoken
language is from three three pieces
depending on how you analyze it people
have made PhD talking about this so this
is a simplification so it's from the
world the words themselves have some
meaning but also the order they appear
in creates new meaning so it's not just
words randomly put there and also it's
the context they're in so we know from
this some context for these words that
we're going to find in our and the
double scope case we know that there
there's job descriptions this data set
is from US jobs we we now have to
consider how we're going to get the
words and how we're going to get the
context so let's look at some example
jobs maybe get some inspiration okay so
here we see see Fleming development
incorporated the crossing about the
company there's talking about some
benefit so they promote with falsely
fraught with it from then basic job
descriptions so let's see a lot of you
mentioned tokenization is like the first
thing that you want to explore data so
how many people here have implemented a
tokenizer
okay cool um so tokens especially
loyalty contacts I think probably more
this is a more general interpretation
it's referring to splitting text up into
words it can also be used in some
context to split text into characters
for example if we talk about encryption
sometimes they'll refer to turning it
into a stream of characters as
tokenization but here obviously we're
talking my LP so well as horribly in the
words of course there's a poem of this
Oh what is a word so can anyone here
give me just a definition of what they
think a word is
a sequence of characters so in that case
so why would you split up a document in
the words thing so voice way so okay so
now we know that there are some
characters which are not words right so
and most I'll say English and similar
language implementations to organization
is about that as far as i'm fiying what
a sequence of characters that we
consider a word and not the characters
that we don't consider a word so we need
to figure out what we want to actually
how we actually want to define these
things so you see the bring us to our
first exercise so again we see our data
so here's some things you are consider
how do you want to have a punctuation if
a word ends in a period should the
period be it be with the other
characters in the last word or should it
be on so how should we treat
contractions English and a few other
languages have these weird things where
sometimes we'll just co-op's words
together should we split them up what
should happen to the apostrophe should
we keep them the other how do you want
to handle numbers and how do I handle
hyphens so as the first exercise we have
this example gel description which is of
course very fake but it just has lots of
common situations if you run into with
tokenization so some of things to
consider is ah let's see so we have jobs
there has the period at the end of it
should that period be attached to job
the numbered list should the token there
be one and then another token foot dot
or should it be a token one dot and also
how do we want to handle salary I mean
this is one of those things about saying
with NLP depending on the context that
you're dealing with you might want to
implement it differently you can imagine
that if a seller appears on gel
description that might be an important
thing to keep as a token if we're
splitting up all punctuation
separate tokens which is a common
default implementation then we have
dollar sign 50 comma three zeroes as
tokens and that's not going to be very
useful we have to then reconstruct
salaries and a later process so I of
course have already implemented my own
tokenizer so I'll talk my why in a
moment but why don't you go ahead and
implement it so Kaiser you have any
questions or or anything else all and
I'll move on probably in a few minutes
and we'll see what you guys come up with
[Music]
quite sure oh there is um so when you
check out the project there should have
been at our file and when you unzipped
it and when you ran the setup file if
you put it into under a data folder
I think there's like a first suggestion
case any of you are not sure where to
start
generalization at least in English and
similar languages is lovely between
identifying the words or identifying the
gaps so sort of pick which one you want
to identify do you want to write
something that finds all the gaps and
then just create a sequence of tokens
from removing them or you are pricing
that finds the words and then you just
pull out all the words from the text
[Music]
so this idea how how many people are
still working on it okay is anyone
finished okay based on space okay hmm
so you see you so you might wanna do
something like a regex so are you
familiar with Python project module okay
cool
well this is why I'm using ltk so I
don't UK actually comes with a Roger
space tokenizer that you can use so I
would say that might be a good one to
start with and I think that one has a
setting about whether you're identifying
gaps or not
so I say write a good rest around that
one might work also what
so same here as you're working on
implementations run it against the
sample job description and see what's
coming out and see whether you you like
the output
okay how many people are still working
okay doesn't see a lot of hands to
either ver-very losted sauce or no one's
working on itself okay
[Music]
so we go and open up my answers
hopefully it doesn't get away too much
okay excellent
so this is what I did to implement it
I know it's reg X's are not exactly the
most readable thing so let me walk
through about the the decisions I made
in making this okay so first we we know
that we want to pull out the the
sequence of characters that define
normal work so like alphabetic
characters right so we want to make sure
that we get those guys so this one's
going to cover that this is going to
pull out sequence of work based
characters so the other thing I want is
I want to be able to pull out the
salaries so I figure will be a good
project for identifying salaries we have
our currency symbols you have some
digits and commas and maybe dots because
and somewhere in Europe for example they
use dots to separate out the thousands
of digits the every three digits and
then I want to pull the punctuation into
something separate so basically if it's
not a word character in soft space pull
into its own token and I use the regex
one for it you could you know almost as
easily use them just the Python right
you know re module so here mine I'm not
identifying the gaps right so i'm fiying
the actual words so are identifying the
gaps that it might be something like
splitting on white space which is
something you see in some other very
simplified token answers okay
circe of outputs okay so we have this is
a description for a generic job dot
let's see how it in our salary of course
I ran this beforehand so I'm not
actually going to be surprised look it
worked
I totally broke this at one try didn't
take me a few tries or anything okay so
now we're going to take it we have a
tokenized function out and we're going
to run that against our our data frame
so we're just use the apply method
against our job descriptions and we're
going to save it so I all sort of
function for saving the for saving the
functions that we create so if you want
you can look in the code that's how that
works it's not really a thing is not
very it's not really important to this
particular talk but we'll probably need
to use these functions later so let's go
on tf-idf so we have two tokens out but
we need some sort of calculation for our
identifying what tokens are important
because we're going to have lots of
periods in there we're gonna have colons
or we have the word duh as well as all
those stuff about the particular job
like data scientist or hospital
administrator
we're gonna have these words in there as
well and we need to find some way of
identifying which ones are important so
we're using tf-idf so the loose
description of tf-idf is it's a number
that will tell you how important a term
is and a document relative to the corpus
town horn how how horn is in the corpus
so really what that works is that you
have your term frequency which is the
count of the number of times the term
occurs in a document
so I'm here and then for IDs I mean
strictly speaking the intuitive
understanding is that it's just one over
the document frequency but generally
people use the log of 1 plus that value
as it helps smooth out some of things it
gives some better it worked a little bit
better than the very basic one but this
is I would say is sort of the default
implementation you'll find if tf-idf out
there so thing is we're not looking at
tf-idf by document we're looking at Kiev
IDF across our corpus so that means we
need to look at an average yet oh yes so
here's some some math so let's go and
actually look at it
so I've written a function here tells it
now I'm average tf-idf so the first
thing we want to do is you want to turn
into back so you might have heard who
here's cure of the term bag of words
okay
we've also heard the term like document
vector but that I think is sometimes
more general because there's other ways
of generating that vector but so the bag
of words is basically a counter like if
you're familiar the Python data data
structure counter of the words and a
doctor in total terms so we're going to
take that and we're just going to take
our term roads so this is where our
passive a in here we're going to produce
counts and then we're going to sum up
those counts so we'll get the sum of the
term frequency and we'll get the
document frequency from those as well by
summing up just the key so we get this
one per document so this will give us
back from our calculation up here after
so at this point we will have the sum TF
as well as this is this this value for
each of the terms so now we have those
we're going Kaltag ideas it's just
taking the log of that value and the
using the number of term rows we have or
number of documents we have so then we
multiply that times the IDF and we get
the sum TF idea and divide it by the
number of documents get the average key
idea and now we have our we'll have a
data frame that has all the cool
information we're looking for so take my
function I'm gonna give it the tokens
from just generated before and let's see
what's there okay
okay this is this tells us some stuff
but not really much we don't get really
an idea of what's the meaning of these
documents we just know how these three
values are distributed so let's look at
the actual words
so let's look I'm going to sort by the
sum TF so this is going to be in
ascending order so what would what words
do we expect to have lo some TF untoward
yeah so these are words that occur very
few times in life in the corpus Carol
SDO has some some abbreviations here
okay so what do we expect what words you
expect to be at the other side of this
yep
and remember just the tokenization so
also tall man in period are there
because you haven't done any
normalization yet okay so what do we
expect for low values of IDF also
similar to so we expect there's to be
service this contrary behavior between
IDs and yes a little bit so if it has a
low IDF that means it occurs in many
documents so we'd expect like similar
words as they had very high high TF yep
okay and low TF idea or SAR high TF idea
or in what words to expect here words
that appear and maybe like one document
Terrell again so different ones well
what's interesting is now we know that
these are words occur in one document
once and so at the very least I get
issue all a very fun rare word if you
have a corpus and it word only in a
particular word only occurs once an
entire corpus
it's called a hotbox waggle men on so
so there now you've all learned a new
word today or new phrase I should say
hot box logo meant on
it's a Greek so I believe it occur it
means a like a like what one like a
single word or simply like this
basically means it means pretty much
exactly what it is it's a word that
appears once so it's a once work it's uh
it's not like modern Greek it's actually
some older stuff like half ax I don't
really think is much of a used word
anymore anyway so the other side average
tf-idf for low values yeah we're
expecting the same thing here's here's
an interesting so a little values of
tf-idf it's similar to high values of of
IDF that's interesting why is that the
lowest one okay Fourier set let's look
at this look at the other side
interesting
hi guys the tf-idf or all these stop
words this is not what we want it at all
if I did was supposed to solve our
problems finding these four words for us
what's going wrong here yeah but but you
don't want these words the and occurs in
our corpus that doesn't tell us anything
we want you want the cool meaningful
words we don't want to call an asterisk
so what's wrong with how we've done it
so far that we're seeing these words
enough cool words up here yeah so
basically FIDs doesn't solve all our
problems for us it's a vanilla
implementation there's also these many
implementations as as our people who
have learned FIDs it's
there's many ways to do this and really
what we're seeing here if we will go to
some TF and idea is the values of some
TF are way better so it doesn't matter
that the IDF is penalizing it the sum TF
is overriding it so we could of course
for in a long time tweaking to just the
right weights to combine them to find
the right words or as you were hinting
at by saying that they're soft words we
could just remove the things some of the
things we don't like until we get some
of the stuff we do so we know tf-idf
comes originally from the world of
search and the way it sort of works is
that you have a query and that query is
made up of different terms you break up
that query into terms you find there
tf-idf for all the documents and then
you sum up the other one you guys for
there are of course many other
implementations of search but this is
sort of the basic element HP
implementation you might do in a course
or something like that so let's
implement that so first we need to make
an index so counseling tf-idf
for all our words that will be expensive
and I like that for them for every query
let me how horrible and why do you need
to recalculate it again and again
instead what we can do is I'm going to
build a corpus from words to documents
so that I can initially pull out the
documents have any of the words I'm
interested in and then do the
calculation so first you need to build a
document index so that's just taking out
the tokens and doing the counter again
so just like we did before and I said I
get RTF so next you make what's called
an inverted index
so the way that works is for each I'm
going to go over each one of the
documents and I'm going to go over each
one of the words and I'm going to update
that in a dictionary and that way we'll
be able to go from our terms to the
documents that contain them so here we
see all the IDS of the words that
contain that Scalia mark okay so it's
important Oken eyes that we saved
earlier hopefully that works okay okay
so in our search so they asked their
work so now we have we're going to want
the query we're going to on our
documents to be able to actually return
stuff we're going to want our normal
index so we can once we get these IDs
look up our documents we're going to on
our inverted index and our idea because
you don't there's no reason to
recalculate that whatever processing is
done this is something that's important
to consider and a lot of NLP things if
you're trying to do something that
matches one piece of text to another
always make sure that the processing
occurs on the same on both sides I think
probably everyone here says oh of course
that makes sense but I would also advise
you always double-check that the
processing is the same on both sides
because many situations we think it's
the same and then Oh someone had a
different version of something here or
they had a slightly different intonation
here or forgot to add a step here so and
then we also have the limit of the
dolphin to return so the way this is
going to work is I'm going to process my
query and we get a set of the terms out
that way if I look for something like
[Music]
job job job job it was a search for job
no reason that to multiply the score
humans take further query by being all
the way of marking the importance of
terms so now we have these terms we can
get out the filter set the set of ID's
that contain any of our terms so we're
doing here so we have that filter set we
can then get the TS for them for the
terms that are in our query now we have
our IDs for the so yeah so the term
IDF's for terms so we multiply that now
we have our tf-idf
we do our score we just sum them and we
sort and let's see so I want to search
for data scientists our jobs okay let's
see what comes up first
well interesting we get a DBA job so a
reason anyone have any reasons why we
would get a DBA job instead of data
scientists Oh
as I said what yeah exactly right so um
this is a useful to remember I mentioned
before about the order of words being
important right so if you don't put
something to look at the order then if
you have data in this thing and
scientists somewhere else well I don't
match that just the same as something
talking about data scientist this is why
language is the words the order of the
context and other stuff but we'll just
stick to those we found
okay so we have tf-idf so now we want to
visualize it now since a lot of you ask
your questions are installing for cloud
I imagine it's already been spoiled how
we're going to be visualizing this but
any other suggestions for how we might
use tf-idf
to visualize what's in our corpus
hmm Oh mr. Grasso you could do like a
plot of the bus or the different values
I have there yes sir where else if
you'll be doing a plot a scatter plot of
TF versus IVF can you take some more
information any other it is yes let's
see oh look what pencil offend family
service I have no idea what to say right
because I didn't run this query now it
looks like it's just a long one it's a
really long one and of course yeah
exactly what you're hinting at it
happened is that we search for a common
word and just pulled off a really long
document because you have long documents
they're gonna have lots of periods in
them or walk to the word and or so my
god and of course those are going to
dominate which is why I said there's
also different implementations of tf-idf
and our ones out there are supposed to
correct for document length but the
Wikipedia links have all that
information so that's one of the
visualization okay so we're going to
those other attributes we're going to
turn those into segments because
remember we want to look at the context
so we have the generic context so these
are the job descriptions so in the
United States but we want to look at
more detailed context so the jobs that
require a lot of experience the jobs
that require a lot of Education or very
little education jobs that are part-time
or hourly so I'm just going to build
these these filters that were going to
use later on just pandas indexes so
really what's coming out of all these is
a list of kind a series of boolean
values so let's continue on where to
save these for future use
huh so average CFIDS we function we use
from last time now I also have those
functions that showed last time ever at
another module that's how I'm running
them here so let's see what's there
okay so these are the color words that
we expecting okay so let's plot tf-idf
frequencies okay that's a fall yet to
function yes so that's much arise I
guess isn't quite for you this is this a
scatter plot I should have named it
better okay so this is a scatter plot so
let's let's talk about those go on so we
have some TF on the bottom and they have
IDF on the vertical axis and I have a
colors set to be connected to the
average tf-idf so red means really high
blue means well with absolute you know
like dark red being the highest value
dark blue being the lowest value so it's
interesting that we that it seems like
some TF is pretty much describing our
tf-idf values the exception of these
guys of course they're going to be
darker this is the point that is that we
talked about earlier about TS dominating
because we have these punctuation in
these soft words all that supplement so
let's look at what these two guys are so
we want to find a for solution ones are
over 20,000 so that's going to look at
all these points okay these are soft
words right these are the words through
super high current frequency also super
high average tf-idf because term
frequency is dominating okay so let's
look at the ones right here to have
greater than Q IDF but also greater than
10,000 TF
these two things so asterisk and and and
dot even though I'm not sure I don't
think that's actually that's um that's a
central dot I believe I don't think it's
the period and exactly yeah so that this
is what we're seeing for these so that
there's just lots of bulleted lists I'm
sure if you look at job descriptions
you'll see those are common formats that
people use but obviously they're not so
common that they're ubiquitous otherwise
they would have a lower IDF value okay
so now let's get to work laps so far
more clouds are really fun and generally
intuitive way of representing these
weights for words so let's see is
throughout my average tf-idf okay so I
just presented this to you could you
really tell what this corpus was about I
mean you'd be like well experience in
there and I guess sales Wow you might be
able to get this table so if it doesn't
really give you a characterization
almost any English dataset is going to
look not too different from this okay
let's try some of the other rows let's
do some TF okay that definitely didn't
work IDF if I presented this to you you
would think that this is clearly
something about Microsoft Excel I don't
know what that is and hanging it's
apparently very important maybe this has
something to do with the 2000 election
in Florida I don't know but we don't see
chat in here must surprise this a really
old reference so I applaud you for those
of you who lacked it you're very
merciful okay
okay so I wrote this function that will
so that we don't have to go through each
cycle any beforehand what it will do is
it will do the scatter plot it will do
the overall World Cup for cloud and then
it will use those segments you made
before and you'll create a word cloud
for each segment so it takes a little
bit while to run so it's a few perhaps
only 11 plots going to do let's see okay
so we have 35,000 tokens here's our plot
we saw above and let's look through some
of these categories okay not really a
lot of difference here or here yeah
basically all these les yeux swords are
getting our way so let's try and
normalize some of these so how many
people here have implemented stemming or
limitation how many people here know
what limit ization is okay so for those
who don't live in is also sometimes
called salt 7 with the idea being that
ah stemming let's say in this word
realize - assuming it gives you the root
word it gets you the step I I'm sorry I
know that's pedantic but they're
technically different like for example
if I had one of the favorite words for
talking about this issue is also very
long word and have this
antidisestablishmentarianism right so if
I were to stem that I would get any any
guesses
it sounds okay so if I removed all the a
sixes I would get that but depending on
what you actually doing with your corpus
you want to figure what you removed so
yeah if you want to remove all your
affixes you'll get establishment because
anything less than that is not
technically derived from English right
there's a connection between stable and
establish but the connection dint occur
in English or did occur in modern
English so I would say that it's
depending on the problems you faced
sometimes you'll want to remove
derivational suffixes so that's like
realize hopeless these are words that
will take one word and create a related
one but it's often times I will turn
like a noun to a verb or an adjective to
avert to a noun let's say and then
there's inflectional ones the partial
ones it's the same word it's just maybe
a little bit of information has changed
or it's a different function in the
sentence so oftentimes you want to
remove inflection because there's not a
lot of meaning lost when you remove
those depending on what you're doing if
the number of things being referred to
as important don't rule the flesh you'll
stuff the original stuff is if you don't
care as much for the very specific
details of the meaning of your words the
remove derivational which is why you see
a lot of simple search approaches remove
derivational suffixes as well because
you realize real requirement you kind of
want them to all be returned you might
do something where you have multiple
indexes and you combine them somehow
limitation okay so those few people know
what limitation any volunteers to
describe what it is
so cane it's not quite root word so that
the different is that definition
globalization has to do with a
dictionary so when you look up a word in
a dictionary
let's say I look up calling what will I
see
I'll see a present participle of the
verb call and it will say like maybe
what page or if it's online will be like
a link to call and then coal will
actually have the definition
so for these dictionary entries I
actually have a definition that word up
there the head word is traditionally
called a lemma so that's what lemma says
it's finding this canonical form now
again the examples are giving here are
English and you can get very very
different considerations depending on
the the grammar of the language you're
working on English is pretty simple but
so with English if you're looking for
the root of other words the stem of a
word with a state Stajan alright
they get the verbs stage the stem of
that is sang there we go
now what would the lemma be of the verb
exactly yeah so you you get to keep the
meaningful form that recognizable form
if you do limit ization the trade offs
as we'll see here
so I included our in the data set some
lemmas I found from Lawrence Anthony's
website so you're going to need to hold
in memory the mapping for utilization
but the stemming you need to run some
algorithm to decide how you want to
remove things so it's all the time sort
of this time-space trade-off and of
course again depending on the language
these trade-offs may look very different
so let's look so here so here's some
words we have English llamas so I want
to find the the llamas that have the
most associated words not surprisingly
it's B B it's a very weird word in
English has all sorts of extra forms
that other words don't have so what's
interesting here remember I said about
the make sure has the same processing
this is already assuming a kind of
tokenization it's assuming that you're
tokenization splits off contractions at
the apostrophe keeping the apostrophe on
the second part so probably with this
word for this purpose that's not really
important but it's just something to
remember okay so that's our look at I
want to find collisions well which words
when I look them up could there be
multiple lemmas for because if there's
too many of those that might be a
problem okay so we have haven't was
that's the contractions have that issue
just looks to non subtractions life and
live will plural wife is lives and
third-person singular of lives lives so
that's where they collide we see some
other collisions here and it's not that
bad what about twenty or so okay
let's hope this actually affect us I
don't take it well
so never move on to our next exercise so
we now have this English lumps so this
is a dictionary from a work from a word
in some form to its lemma and I want you
to implement a method our same sample
value there the influence limitation
I've already done stemming or rather I
should say snowball the snowball project
is already done stemming and NLT K lets
you use snowball so well you think about
what your insulin station nice to us
snowball is there's this algorithm is
very common for something called a
porter summer I'm gonna hear heard of
that okay so Porter servers is sort of a
very frequently used and well heard of
algorithm for removing suffixes from
English words so the person that the
person behind that and a few other
people made a special language for
implementing summers called snowball and
so you see and a lot of libraries like
NL TK has it open an open NLP is such as
Java library penalty some search engines
they'll have these a lot of them have
these snowball simmers already pre-built
into them so right now I'm just using
the one for mental TK to do the stemming
I'm using snowball English summer
appropriately enough so now I want
everyone to implement limit ization so
the elimination function should take the
tokens some tokens so the tokens the
output in the first exercise this list
of terms and the mapping that we have
available up above this English limos
and it should output a new list of the
lemma ties words I would also say let's
consider the other stuff we want to do
we want to reduce case we want to remove
punctuation so
[Music]
[Music]
you
so expect this one might be a little bit
easier than the first so just because
you know you already have the mapping
provided so prosody how many people have
finished okay I will wait a little
longer
[Music]
okay how many people are still working
on it oh okay
you see the two moment
so one thing I think you know some
people may want to consider if you've
never done some limit Iser before what
do you want to happen if you don't find
the lemma so some of you may have
noticed I actually ran a cell while you
guys were working it just because the
stepper takes a little time so I just
ran it while you guys were working
okay then we're all still working on
this okay okay
so I family's here and we move ahead and
show what I did it's not something most
complicated function typewritten but
yeah just it loops over them furs away
the non-alphanumeric ones or done
alphabetic ones or say lower case ISM
and then looks up that the dilemma if
it's not there uses what it was getting
okay so as you can see here at the
stemmer ran for about thirty seconds
which is by around where you guys were
working because it could be very painful
to sit here and stare at a crowd while I
just wait for for the processor to go so
I'll see how long the llama tiser will
take one second what a wonderful thing
if you have memory to use okay so now
let's do the the analyze function
excusing so first we're to look at the
stems and then we'll look at the lemmas
afterwards so here we got our eleven
plops
okay so now we have v just other 16,000
stems let's look at this guy
okay so these bullets that we had before
they're gone okay not surprisingly
remove those okay let's look at these
words well okay it's a little bit better
we draw the punctuation we have what was
manage goal management something related
to experience we have some more
meaningful words so you get a rough idea
of what was in this document but as it's
already been pointing out we have those
common words sometimes called soft words
list so there are different categories
are different segments exercise
so five plus years experience not a lot
different
it looks like manage isn't as important
for the five plus here's only sound see
it photo Harris I just I just kind of
see it okay no it's important for both
I'll see any good differences that looks
like sale is a little more important in
two to five years than it is a five plus
let's see work seems to be important for
both of these not a lot here okay we're
seeing Clinic interesting okay so still
can't really get a good idea of this so
suppose it lemmas although we have a
large amount of llamas that are kept
I'm not really expecting much of a
difference in the effect here other than
the word clouds gonna be a little bit
easier to read okay so overall not much
differently so stemming although
interesting we do see let's see where as
manager doesn't appear to be as
important or manic which is what was the
stem version let's see soon as anyone
see his reef manager here we have
management we might have manage oh here
we have managed so stemming as I said is
a little more aggressive it will remove
the derivational suffixes so management
is a derivation from manage right
manager is a derivation for manage a
limit Iser doesn't necessarily remove
that you can of course always build a
lemma dictionary that will do that for
you but in this case this one is just
our log hazardous removing inflectional
suffixes so see a little bit of a
difference here
Oh see whoa-ohh experience is Oh
that's the overall loss the first one
okay so not much there so save off or
start our work and we will move on to
the next section
so stop words okay so we identified this
from almost the beginning we're going to
need to remove these words these words
are blowing up our implementation at the
IDF and we don't want to spend the time
having to find the perfect combination
tf-idf you rid of them so where's your
movies because we know what they are or
do we so I try to find out the root of
where the term stop words came from and
I couldn't seem to find it it's such a
year I don't know for me I find it's
very unintuitive way to refer to them
that one here is out here know the root
of that no mystery okay
okay so let's let our data back so I
don't see K comes to zone set of soft
words and there's a lot of a lot of NLP
NLP related projects out there that come
with a set of soft words a common one
that I see used by a lot of people is in
leucine which is a java based search
index even I think theirs is actually
based off of someone else's but I'm not
sure about that so I'm using the English
one but let's take a look at it so if a
about above after okay so looking at
these um anyone here character a guess
what these things have in common other
than just there's a PF is like
grammatically or or or they're mean and
wise semantically what do these have in
common very context-specific
how do you mean not very okay so so how
do you mean
yeah so um so basically the meaning of
their they're not they don't care
contain a lot of meaning in the end it
you will and I just say you know by pan
couldn't you don't really know what I'm
talking about you just have those words
oh yes ah yes subject with them let's
see
ah
[Music]
oh yeah so this is a conservative yes so
yes I so that's interesting I think that
so the Linguistics description for these
again towards what you're describing is
these are function ones so they don't
actually carry a lot of semantic weight
themselves they just help words relate
to the context and to other words so in
this case like for example most okay mo
we sort of have a generic idea of what
most means but it's sort of like a like
it it is you know everyone here is very
familiar of programming so it's sort of
like a function is what you're saying
with a server subject but you need to
pass in something to make must mean
something or Mozart most mean someone
most what most of what same with mom so
I know when I say this is my phone then
we all know that means when I say it but
if you were to talk about like oh this
is my computer it's the same mine has
different meanings so these are words
that have the service functions they
don't really have they're only in so
those are easy candidates to remove as
soft words but there are some situations
where you wouldn't want to remove them
Clara forehand where I said we're not
going to do syntax parsing well we were
we would definitely not want to remove
these because these are important cues
and understanding syntax but I would
also suggest that there are other
scuffles depending on the domain so a
problem I worked on in a past in the
past job was there clinical so in
clinical documents you often don't care
about the word patient patient occurs
all over the place that's a soft work
and clinical text so in job descriptions
what do you guys think would be
additional software's you can't
[Laughter]
well we have I have an exercise for you
to do this so so first let's look for
some more different candidates yeah I
think that out probably I mean I think
this comes this conference isn't really
too heavy on buzzards I've definitely
seen much heavier Buzzard conferences
right so you know maybe maybe like if
some conferences big data might be a
soft word for them or deep learning it
could be a soft word so let's see let's
look at our lemmas let's look at the
tf-idf values let's look at highest
tf-idf for lemmas okay so we see some
ones that we in here that we know are
definitely soft words right we see and -
and uh see all these words we know so
it's just the case that all the top ones
are going to be stop words up experience
is that software yes are you sure that's
it's not necessarily a software right
because it could be it could actually be
meaningful job we expected a cur lot but
not well it may be a software depending
on what you're doing we were trying to
identify how much experience is needed
it's definitely not as awkward let's
look some others customer skill service
who knows these are hard we'll see skill
what do you think stopped work not
software software okay yeah I agree
generous it depends on what we're doing
if we're looking for a list of skills
this would not be a soft word but we're
not doing that
okay so let's describe so this is a
distribution of the average tf-idf IDF
some pf4 llamas okay so it looks like so
let's look at some of these values up
here so it looks like for average
tf--idf 75% are below point 0 1 and we
are looking at these ones with like
values above 1 so these are definitely
sort of abnormal for the amount of ever
value of average CFI left ok so let's
look at the words that our that are not
software just local with our what the UM
distributions okay so we see okay so
when the disciplines that are supple yes
so we see the average is way higher it's
like 80 times higher than for 750 plus
outside for the mean it's not them l
let's it's pretty big that's pretty much
so okay we have definitely differences
so it really seems like average tf-idf
is a good indicator but I don't know if
I would make a hard and fast rule when
you implement your your stop your extra
soft words we're going to harden
festival but I would say that you might
get some my troop some words that are
useful stuff look at the ones that are
not soft words ahsoka let's see what
they look like so they have experience
works uses a high average tf-idf
non-stop words at least not according to
an old cat business client must so
interesting must that should have been
in there so
ah let's look at the description okay
is this was point zero four for the
general vocabulary so I would say go
ahead and pick your own soft words now
you can either make a list or maybe just
like select a group from the data frame
however you want to do it
so the thing with this one is it can be
super easy or super difficult depending
on how you choose to do it I would say
if you are manually creating your list
this is sort of is a good lesson about
NLP is that there is there's nothing
better than your own brain and
understanding language it just so
happens that you operate much slower
than a computer because you can do all
this really cool stuff and you're also
not really built for doing NLP you're
built for just understanding language
and hunting gazelle so whenever you have
the opportunity to have an offline
process where you can utilize your own
evolved expertise in the matter that's
definitely going to help you
[Music]
okay how many are still working on it
okay
give it a little bit more
[Music]
okay so for Lancer because I just did a
handcrafted less rice credit few any
interesting implementation Aryan people
want to talk about their implementation
oh okay oh okay did anyone try the
manual approach where they just look for
words on their own oh so did you find
any good words you want to share oh okay
cool yeah this was a good ones I would
say one of our one of our segments is
hourly so an hourly paid job versus a
salaried job so I say maybe salary
wouldn't be good but click on those that
was one that I definitely did think of
that's definitely a good one let's let's
what I know what I got
so see I got requirements because it's
so common IRL someone is think this was
must is one I'm sort of surprised it
wasn't in the NPK one let's say position
work ability company job look and able
look is it technically a function word
but it's used in English in a very a
very generic way able and then all the
URLs were placed with WWE example.com so
when I was first going through this I
saw this coming up so I had those
removed and then May which could be a
month but it's also is also a function
of work because a lot you know you may
do this I figure okay if I lose people
referring to specific months I'm not
going to be too upset off at so
so now we get to look at the clean
version so this should definitely look
better so we've addressed all of our
issues you were talking about before
we've got rid of the punctuation we've
watched some of the words down we've
removed the soft words so we still see
the same distribution even though it
does it's not quite as sharp of a drop
of got rid of some words that were on
the far far right there so see if I were
to show this word cloud to you you'd
probably able to guess this is something
probably some of our jobs because you
see experience and skill and services
sale this I think we give that a good
basic understanding of what's our job
let's look at the other second side five
plus years experience let's compare that
to five okay so experience is being both
sale is slightly bigger in two to five
let's see um interesting so management
is definitely bigger in the five plus
years customer is bigger in two to five
years let's look at one to two okay we
see experience still poor not surprising
because this is a segment defined by
experienced patient that's interesting
[Music]
by the way whatever I'm looking at these
are saying that interesting don't worry
I'm coming to that later so it's of
masters to read compare that to
bachelor's medical okay interesting
let's see experience is still big for
both of those ah see
so she's degree mm sale is definitely
very big here let's look at hourly ok
service hour okay that's just a good one
it looks like salaries apparently not
that important here so I think you would
have been fired without I probably
didn't how much well we'll see
no spoilers oh so part time time here
our let's see supervising okay so I
don't know this is definitely better
than the previous ones but this doesn't
really give us a solid understanding so
we do something more to look at this
remember we talked about these these are
three parts to getting out the meeting
so we've looked at the words you've done
our work with the words gotten the good
words out we have the contracts we have
these segments we know those job
descriptions we now need to look at that
order so the thing is we don't want to
do syntax parsing that is slow so I know
some of you may remember the outline for
the beginning but any suggestions for
how we might look at the order of the
words and get the meaning out of those
yes okay so save our work so yeah we're
going to construct engrams so actually
before I going that one and one here
no engrams are enough to explain them
exactly see it's not that bad okay
there's this of course what complicated
versions about one called a skip gram
which is where you also look at words
with other words in between but we're
not looking at those if you look up and
Graham's Wikipedia you can find that
information
so now you know Graham's diagrams and
trigrams have special names throughout
for that special into world number low
number ones and of course as someone
who's always very interested in language
I noticed that they're mixing Latin and
Greek roots which is an abomination
but you know what they say when in Rome
it's all Greek to me Paul's for laughter
okay so let's see what comes out from
this very well instead that's a quick
brown fox jumped over the lazy dog so
you know Graham's are just the terms by
Graham's are the quick quick brown brown
fox trigrams the quick brown quick brown
fox brown fox jumped so you have the
sliding window of length n move the
other document so let's load our data so
there's something here before I could
read and spoiler for yourself what the
problem might have you just run an
Engram abstraction over our tokens
I'm sorry ah well it could be so if
you're doing like a large job so if
you're pulling out like 5 grams over a
huge corpus yeah that can be expensive
especially if you're doing some of stuff
like we're doing like idea you can have
this huge dictionary that's having this
pointer from all these different worms
so yeah it can be expensive it can be
time-consuming depending on how you're
doing it and you have a problem so okay
that's another one how about is there a
problem in and could be potentially
violate the meanings of these words
depending on how we implement it okay
well that's one that we're sort of we
saw are already accepted because we had
to get rid of those to do the work
beforehand there's another there's
another way
there we go across expenses so and in
this case let's look at the sense I have
at the beginning here engrams are fixed
with width sentence is fixed with
sequence of words pulled from a text
let's use the following follow up so if
I'm pulling out by grams
I'll get depending on how you treat your
- ization and grams are are fixed so on
then get we've blog we've dropped these
so we get pull text and then text use
public as you probably drop these words
texts and use that's not a by grammar in
ours and the sentence is here that's
violated the meaning of what we're doing
so that means before we do any grams we
have to do set this boundary detection
so during the beginning where I use this
fishing analogy I say only go so deep at
no deeper this is a situation where
we're probably going deeper than we may
have initially thought we need to
actually run a model based program to
split in the census that seems like a
little bit more NLP than will be to make
sense for exploratory work but this is I
think one of the traditions where just
remember that the sentence about
detection models we different for each
corpus so if you're exploring it go
ahead and use a default one it'll
probably work fine and that's this is
probably as deep as we want to go
because anything after this we're really
getting you know into the really maybe
diving too deep into the water here so
I'm just cooling the user comes with an
LT k how he came as it comes with the
Pumped tokenizer
so that means I'm going to need to redo
all the processing I did again so I'm
loading up my functions I'm going to
find a new function here noise no works
it takes the description it's going to
break it up into sentences and this is
going to run all the functions over them
so we're on this so this is take a few
moments and we'll take that back because
we're not doing stemming right that took
a really long time oh look it finished
already so I don't need to solve loads
the segments back okay so now I'm going
to create a convenience function for
myself I know TK comes with a function
for generating engrams but you need to
give it n but I don't want to have to
make a long call to n l TK engrams so on
so I'm just going to make this function
let's go wrap it I'll pass it an end and
it will give me a function back and then
I'll take that function and I'll run it
over over the data frame here we go
so we have our sentences we created up
here so this is um this is all the
sentence tokens that we have so let's
see so what's so what's contained in the
sentences is a list of the process
sentence so each row has a list of a
list of strengths and from that I'm
going to output a list of strings made
up of the engrams so I'll do it with two
firs actually let's take a look at these
employer midstream midstream service
service something I see our staff staff
accept accept the resume okay
so totally expected so let's analyze it
so as you can see we actually Alma we
are going to see a much larger set of
terms here so let's go ahead so we're
see a sixteen hundred percent increase
in our vocabulary size for this let's
see there we go
so again we still see some you but not
sure if you remembered in the last one I
ran this number was ten thousand
so if much bigger vocabulary but that
means the some TF is much lower now so
if look what's here so overall these are
our by grams
okay so we're seeing your experience
full-time part-time customer service
communication skills or communication
skill so I think if you were to look at
this it was pretty easy to tell you if I
my jobs you might think you're talking
about resumes they do have some over
tabularium
but you definitely think this is somehow
job-related so we have a good
characterization here let's look at our
segments five plus years minimum year
okay your experience we expect those
those are probably minimum years
experience may be our minimum and that's
some number you are engineer an engineer
UI interesting
say two plus years okay looks kind of
similar but we see bachelor's degree is
more important
we'll see communication skills important
of both your experience minimum year Oh
interesting
maybe that's from because number we've
dropped Oman off of airports maybe this
is from minimum X years experience which
means perhaps my focus Asia algorithm
was incorrect
this one actually did know going into it
so I've been right you know if you want
to continue exploring us afterwards do
trying different things on those
functions but what if you use experience
also we have okay high school looks like
more probably here than what we saw in
the past
uh-huh she's master's degree oh look
master degree ba so degree Oh silver
bullet interesting okay what do you
expect to be an important word for
associate degree rubber so we have
master's degree have this one vouchers
have you had this one what do we expect
for associates great 33 so looks like we
have a pretty strong signal for these
segments okay hourly per hour
okay that's looks pretty good driver
license is kind of prominent there
interesting that's telling us some other
into other intuitive information
I'm definitely lucky diagrams it's
giving us some good info part-time
colors spring say it with me now
interesting you say with me
okay okay supervising policy procedure
okay this one's not giving us a lot okay
so so we have a silver bullet an
engineer UI UI engineer so let's use our
search function we made all the way back
way
and we're a search of Silver Bullet okay
and sure enough there's a company called
C Silver Bullet and they post the main
jobless data set just of the gas the
thing with engrams we're getting more
information from our data set and coming
here I've had experience with machine
learning oh okay good so then you know
what it means when you're getting more
information from your data set your
overfitting to your data set and that's
really what engrams willingness to their
lives really just get specific
information understand our data side so
let's continue to look at larger engrams
and see how that that continues to
affect us as we look deeper okay so
let's do trigrams so we're going to see
again and 61% increase over by Graham's
they're not huge you have to consider
that once you through a certain size for
your vocabulary especially in very
formulaic corpora you may not see a
continued explosion in the number of
terms because you may have a lot of
documents containing very similar
phrases so see
okay so supply me out with 1200 to 300
for that maximum value here now see
overall the highly interesting equal
opportunity employer so this is one I
was mentioning before hand with
formulaic sentences you see a lot of job
descriptions will have stuff like this
so let's go through some other stuff
[Music]
okay minimum sales experience with to
the park okay so definitely there's
something interesting going on here two
to five years here ah this is not this
is not very good
this is verbal written communication
written communication skill we're seeing
these formulaic sentences being
represented many times because let's say
you have a formulaic sentence this will
say six tokens long well how many
trigrams will I produce multiple
equal-opportunity employer is probably
not indicative of a job that needs 2 to
5 years experience it's just a common
phrase ok what a few years what is who
years a experience okay that's
definitely seems more meaningful ha what
you totally could I didn't but yes I
would say W be worthwhile doing then you
might get some use out of the trigrams
mm-hm
targets miles okay okay so this is
interesting
do you really think Pikeville Medical
Center is important to all jobs with
master's degrees probably not this is
probably again us getting too deep in
their own data set boss Missouri okay
qualification bachelor degree okay
that's good to see um so if it's degree
yeah well hey we're a lot of the
segments we're seeing diminishing
returns at this point for some of them
like hourly and for the one that wanted
to use experience we're seeing some
useful stuff like here pay per hour hour
per week high school diploma those are
good
part-time Colorado spring and
supervising get knowledge useful stuff
here so okay so we're seeing the
formulaic phrases high school diploma
some of these things are matching our
intuition that's good we got these weird
ones
Carlos spring Colorado and engineer UI
engineer and UI engineer UI so let's
figure out what that is
any guesses
maybe within this is Lisa ulema
so what would have been there before
processing so that would that get us
engineer you are engineer but then why
do we also have UI engineer yuan put so
like so engineers if you did like
engineering : UI engineer that would
guess and Jun as you are engineer but
why would we have UI engineer you walk
and then they set it again UI engineer
[Music]
this removal well
back in that can cause a lot of oddities
that's not what this is though so
look at them SEO this is like the
classic implementation of SEO what what
are they explaining here what are they
getting why why would they do this
it's a member to was part of the score
are they actually working on right
because when we talk about TF idea so
what are they what are they boosting by
doing this yeah exactly so people knew
this formulation so I said I want to
hire TF IDs because I know and tf--idf
if I have a high enough TF it doesn't
matter this is the idea I can overcome
it so I'm just going to repeat that this
consequence you know sorry does everyone
here know SEO stands for search engine
optimization so when you want to make
sure that like your website's found
there's all sorts of stuff you can do
and there's a bit of an arms race
between people who make indexes and
people who put stuff in indexes you know
you you person who makes index they want
our own algorithm to determine what's
important they don't want the people
adding in there to being able to
manipulate the importance but to other
people the other hand you know you want
your website or your job to be found so
you want to do stuff to get yourself
more notice so this is probably you know
useful when you're doing when you're
making it a so especially for search if
you find this you're like oh I need to
come up with a way to solve that which
I'm not doing here so let's look at
quarter grams so we're not going to see
much of an increase I sort of um yes
there are can see much of an increase
here let's see
so we still the formulaic bracelet very
important we're going to see more of us
over fitting these these jobs around
that will connected the clinical or
Pikeville Medical beforehand those are
gonna be popping up there okay this
would definitely very different where we
went from having like a top value when
we had this the dilemma the clean lemmas
of like 10,000 10,000 160 we've nothing
is occurring a lot yeah there's nothing
really prominent here is this a bunch of
these so generic phrases mm-hmm
to five years experience again formulaic
phrases at this point we we've dived too
deep and now we're just finding
anglerfish or whatever will be
appropriate in this analogy let's see
anything interesting here sale sale sale
so let's see see again it looks like
it's part of an address probably this
might be an address other to receive
road here in Boulevard here maybe like
similar what happens with
www.example.com maybe the addresses were
removed and they put all those in there
so let's go through with that sale sale
sale is we probably guess one of those
so ah let's see so the idea is that when
you're making these engrams there's more
unique ways to make a Quadra gram than a
trigram right so you have so ignoring
how language works for a second if let's
say we're just picking four elements
from our vocabulary obviously you have a
much bigger chance of much bigger
population of length four then like
three the reason why it's not much
bigger is because like I said how
language works is you can't necessarily
pick any for words and just put them to
governor so that's what we're now seeing
a big increase but we are seeing an
increase if you have a big really
diverse corpus you would expect to see a
continue to increase for a large amount
of anagrams we have a relatively small
corpus it's not very diverse there's all
sort of the same kind of document sale
here okay yep looks like they did
similar I see out at the bottom
okay so let's save our work so
I think I may be running out of time but
this is it very much to do this is a map
right now is our sort of encourage you
if you want to to run ourselves to play
with us on your own especially if you
did your own implementations because I
did is I saved off the results from my
models that I built
so I'm using the city trees let's see
here's our data so I'm using the tf-idf
vectorizer from SK learn SK learn is a
library Python for doing machine
learning how many here how many people
here are familiar else can learn okay
good good so you know the argument in a
tf-idf vectorizer called analyzer
basically what we've done so far is
implement that we've implemented all the
steps so we can now use these different
functions and construct our own
analyzers and see how they perform
differently for the ball so we're going
to try and do some predictions of
decision trees we'll try to predict
education level experience and then the
three boolean is hourly as part-time is
supervisor
so I'm using decision tree because you
can understand decision tree is pretty
easy to explore here's one I made for
which one is this I think this is hourly
so I'm positive that probably the foxy
salary
the top one is per hour so if per hour
has a lower tf-idf
but it's going to go left I so but if it
goes right we go from having 3900 versus
451 which is 3900 non hourly jobs for
351 Alawis we go to having 15 non hourly
118 out of them so helps us whittle down
the data set as our decision trees work
they make purer and purer subsets of the
data so I don't have more time to
explain it but I would recommend you
look at multiple yeah but also my
colleague from indeed Joe McCarthy maybe
some of you may have went to a sake this
morning he did this really cool notebook
that goes through decision trees so you
can look through that so I have the
pre-built results if you want to explore
with your own remove them they take a
little bit to run which is why I didn't
want to do it live all right let's see
so I've loaded up my features that I've
already saved and now I've used some
widgets let's get rid of the warning a
[Music]
scalar version okay so so how many
people here are familiar with cross
validation scores how about with like I
was with learning curves right go go go
so what this is this is showing how well
our model is doing on different sizes of
the data on the the data it hasn't seen
and the data it has seen so here we have
tokens so that is the higher values you
put on max depth the more the tree can
absorb the data so the lower values of
the less it gets fitted to the data
minimum samples leave the lower you go
the
the easier it will be for to make a new
role the higher you go the harder it
will be for to make in the world or new
leaf so these are basically controlling
other values for overfitting
so here are the different features so
let's go look that's for every fan we're
going to throw our clean lemons or our
buy grams in our trigrams oh look we
have slight improvement in score which
is you know good but let's look at
something else experience okay it's much
worse but hey we're dutiful I bet you
the other ones are probably worse like
tokens is definitely going to be worse
than this right Dada why do you think
this would have happened
well fortunately I made a word cloud out
of the future importances let's see what
important features are here 5 and 3 all
these numbers they got rid of so
definitely this is a point of you these
different techniques are good for
different situations when we wanted to
look at what sort of book tabulator we
had yeah get rid of the numbers that's
fine you want to build a model for
predicting experience it's probably not
a good idea
share with the types of scores so I
encourage you to take this notebook try
your own implementations or the models
necks parent with them if you want to
use of it other decision trees I just
put some code here to wrap up training
the model so feel free to you know just
modify that a little I know we don't
have a lot of time left any questions
not for this data I have look that in
the past I find that for our smaller
data sets that don't have like a natural
unnatural cluster clusters you don't get
really good results but yeah that's
definitely be a fun one to look at all
right let's go do so so I would say the
real reason I use it is I'm a language a
nerd and I like that it gives me real
worth back okay but the more useful
response would be I would say if if you
have vocabulary that maybe a little bit
more rare so let's say you have
specialized vocabulary think clinical
you may not be able to find the words to
do the data to do limit ization so
stemming might actually being more
useful in situation I would say if on
the other hand if you are expecting
someone to read the output limit is a
she has probably gonna be better and of
course when you look at other languages
like if you have a language has a very
complex grammar so that stem n would be
a very difficult algorithm let me
physician might be an easy way to do so
let's say you were to like with Russian
one authorization might be easier to
implement then set
to your github repo it that pickle DSM
and thank you the binary Oh gibberish
our identity in cookies to look outside
of your identity yes right now you're
looking at all JavaScript I know you
might get another sense of English
language by looking yet yeah so actually
that's an interesting thing what you
might do if you want if you also you
have a small corpus and you want to
characterize what might be special in
that corpus as a whole you could maybe
have a prebuilt model that you've done
on the table Coupee dia and then you
could just compare the difference for
the words that have the most difference
between the two of them that i do
something easy to do yeah any other
questions
looks like it let's thank Alex for that
session
[Applause]